El partido popular y el señor feijo
ha tenido únicamente el apoyo de la extrema derecha
y para la vergüenza de Canarias,
del único voto de 1 diputada de coalición Canaria.
Es decir,
aquel partido
que no cree en las autonomías,
en los estatutos de autonomía,
que no cree en las en la eh cogobernanza política
que quiere eliminar
todas las transferencias que se Han hecho
en este caso a Canarias.
Es el partido con el que coalición Canaria
le da su apoyo,
su voto gratis,
sabiendo además que era 1 investidura fallida.
Este tipo de situaciones,
como decías al principio de la intervención, ¿es?
¿Y qué se espera
de la clase política?
¿Eh? ¿Quiénes somos?
¿Eh? ¿Quién es coalición Canaria
y cuáles son sus propósitos y cuáles son sus propósitos?
Es 1 partido que no cree ahora en la autonomía,
es nacionalista, es el único partido de la cámara
que que no le hace Fox, la extrema derecha.
Tanto es así
que en Lanzarote pactan con la extrema derecha.
¿Es 1 partido que dicen sus estatutos
eh? Que es de corte progresista,
¿nacionalista? ¿De corte progresista? ¿Eh? Eh,
no tendrían que reflexionar
sobre quiénes somos y hacia dónde vamos,
porque oye por respeto sobre todo
a los cientos de personas
que Han depositado su confianza
en esta formación política